il se passe un truc là
très bien très sérieux alors ce soir on
n'est pas là pour parler d'indice qu'on
est par là pour parler d'un film on va
parler d'Amnistie internationale qui
fête ses 40 ans cette année et puis on
va parler des gens qui donnent leur vie
pour sauver celles des autres enfin
c'est pas une raison non plus pour pas
rendre hommage vu qu'on vous tient à
votre talent et à votre travail alors on
va pas parler de Serge Gainsbourg je m'a
beaucoup parlé ces derniers temps on a
même fait une émission tous les deux sur
France 2 un samedi soir en prime time
simplement je voudrais qu'on regarde
juste un petit bout d'un moment très
la vie ne vaut être vécue sans amour
mais c'est vous qui l'avez voulu mon
amour
ne vous
déplaît
en dansant la je venais de
nous nous aimions
le temps d'une
chance
merci
tu nous regardes
[Applaudissements]
bon voilà on voulait quand même rendre
hommage à votre travail avant de parler
d'Amnesty International Amnesty a donc
40 ans ça a été fondé en 1961 par un
avocat britannique qui s'appelle Peter
Benenson pour défendre les prisonniers
oubliés et il disait cet avocat il
reprenait un proverbe chinois il vaut
mieux allumer une bougie que maudire
l'obscurité et c'est pour ça que le
symbole d'Amnesty International c'est
une bougie avec du fil de fer barbelé
autour voilà alors en 1977 Amnesty a
obtenu le prix Nobel de la paix
aujourd'hui il y a un million de membres
dans le monde et la campagne 2000-2001
c'est donc pour dénoncer la torture qui
est encore employée par deux états dans
le monde sur trois c'est à dire qu'il y
a quand même deux pays sur trois ou la
torture est employée comme un moyen de
gouvernement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc comme je disais dans deux
pays sur trois la torture est devenue un
système de gouvernement en torture plus
pour faire parler mais pour faire taire
c'est-à-dire que les gens en fait ils
sont intimidés par la danger des
torturer et il s'exprime plus
oui les choses qui est intéressant c'est
que on ne se demande toujours si
si en parlant avec amusent international
ou le Fédération Internationale droits
de l'homme si ça sert si ça sert à
quelque chose et un cas très intéressant
le 5 février José un étudiant en
Amérique du Sud était menacé d'être mise
à mort si de ne pas les noms de des
personnes dans son dans son dans son
lycée qui était les chefs de
nos révolte contre le gouvernement on
l'a mené de mort on a même emmené
jusqu'en une rivière pour le noyer enfin
lui a mis le pression Amnesty
International fait un chose qui qui est
pour le première fois ils ont mis sur
internet il y a on peut consulter stop
torture point org Internet et bien il y
a eu tellement de monde qui était
intéressé par cette affaire que en trois
jours les garçons étaient libérés c'est
le premier donc ça sert à quelque chose
on peut toujours faire quelque chose on
voit toujours belles horreurs sur le
télévisions qu'on se dit oui mais
qu'est-ce que tu veux dans ces pays-là
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et bien on
peut faire ça on peut s'intéresser on
peut consulter par internet on peut se
faire membres de Amnesty internationale
c'est le moins de choses parce que parce
qu'il y a quelqu'un dans chaque pays qui
veille qui dénonce qui qui
utilise leur vie à faire ce qu'on
aimerait peut-être faire soi-même mais
on n'a pas le temps on a un autre métier
etc le moins de choses peut-être c'est
de faire partir de Amnesty et il faut
une chose plutôt jolie et ça c'est le
pour le 40e anniversaire de Amnesty ils
ont trouvé une idée très beau ils ont
ils ont fait faire une statut qui va
être mise à l'extérieur de Beaubourg un
statut fait pas les universités de de
beaux-arts de Paris et là dessus venez
tous pour coller une sparadrap de votre
maison si vous cavalez le 26 mai 2001
vous dépose une sparadrap pour dire je
suis pas d'accord en fait c'est tout ce
qu'on a envie je ne suis pas d'accord
c'est pas dans mon nom que vous ferez
des tortures des choses qui sont contre
mon conscience à moi il faut dire aussi
pour continuer quand même comme des
sites impliquée dans d'autres dans
d'autres choses la Tchétchénie beaucoup
qui continue
parce que j'ai vu les
ministère de santé qui est venu en
France a brisé ses bras pour qu'ils
puissent pas opérer il est obligé
d'opérer dans un sous-sol où il est
obligé d'enlever plus de bras et des
jambes il est c'est pas il fait plus de
chirurgie amputateur que de chirurgie
esthétique dans ce coin là et parce que
ça pourrit parce qu'il y a le gangrène
et dans tout ça on a l'impression parce
que c'est pas sur les télés actuellement
voilà que ça s'est arrêté ça c'est pas
arrêté on n'ose pas être fâché avec des
Russes donc on fait rien tu peux faire
quelque chose tu peux dire je ne suis
pas d'accord je vais manifester avec
Amnesty ou juste mettre mon nom sur une
liste tu es au dessus de la pas d'accord
ah d'accord bah c'est au-dessus de la
raison des tas rien donc il y a des gens
avec une courage immense dans le pays où
ça se passe qui ose faire quelque chose
et nous ici on risque rien du tout on
marche juste pas à cause de le bœuf ou
le levagephone ou les choses qui nous
involontairement on peut passer cinq
minutes à coller à ce paradis
contre le sida l'Algérie le Tibet les
enfants de la terre avec Yannick Noah
les téléthons est-ce que finalement
comme vous êtes vous êtes une des rares
il y en a beaucoup mais enfin disons que
vous êtes quand même une des rares
artistes à autant vous engager pour des
pour des causes humanitaires est-ce que
vous avez pas peur à un moment d'en
faire trop on peut pas arrêter là on m'a
demandé si je vais à Rwanda si je chante
personne donc je trouve ça irrésistible
et à chaque fois j'apprends surtout là
quand tu es triste si tu penses que les
choses vont mal tu apprends que qu'il y
a des gens qui font des trucs tellement
surprenants dans une vie tellement
désastreuse que finalement tu sors
enrichi par les personnes que tu as
rencontré donc c'est même peut-être un
peu égoïste on peut dire ça plutôt que
d'être malheureux ici
occupez-vous de ceux qui sont plus
malheureux que vous ailleurs
prendre l'avion pour faire le bien quoi
on n'est pas obligé d'aller au bout du
monde on peut aller au coin de la rue
effectivement merci bravo en tout cas
alors
en fait
en fait j'ai une vous avez commencé à
militer avec votre Père qui est un héros
de la deuxième guerre mondiale et vous
faisiez des marches à Londres contre la
peine de mort et quand vous arrivez en
France en 68 vous avez continué c'est
pas quelque chose qui vous a pris une
fois que vous étiez devenu une vedette
c'est-à-dire que dès votre plus jeune
âge votre père vous avez vous avez
concerné avec ces problèmes votre mère
grande comédienne de théâtre qui se
permettait de refuser des rôles avec
Peter rotule parce qu'elle n'est pas les
elle n'est pas dire les gros mots
est-ce que les Français savent pas ce
que les Français savent pas c'est qu'en
Angleterre c'est qu'on parle de ça c'est
qu'en Angleterre avant avant votre
arrivée en France avant slogan avant
Serge Gainsbourg donc le film de Pierre
Grimblat avance ici enfin toute la
carrière
vous étiez déjà vachement connu allant
de vous viviez avec John Barry qui est
un qui est un très grand compositeur on
va écouter ce qu'il a écrit
[Musique]
dans le bassin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien donc comme quoi John Birkin
finalement avant Gainsbourg elle vivait
déjà quand même avec un coup de droit
d'auteur avec un compositeur
mais quand j'étais mariée avec John
c'est vrai que newsuit qui avait dit
John Barry et son Jaguar Type E et sa
femme Type E je ne sais pas si c'était
vraiment un compliment donc je pense que
si lui n'était pas barré en Amérique et
que moi j'avais pas un sort de grands
coups dans le derrière pour me
débrouiller j'aurais rester une femme
assez banale à couler son bain à être
une sorte de femme à la maison parce que
je l'admirais beaucoup et puis j'avais
ma fille Kate personnage infiniment
mériteux elle-même parce qu'elle a crié
elle-même de société pour les drogués
des alcooliques en France et maintenant
photographe très estimable donc Kaito
est quand même venu de cette de cette
marquage
en Angleterre vous avez fait deux films
très importants de Richard Lester qui a
fait après tous les films des Beatles
avec Charlotte et Michel hein vous étiez
débutante toutes les trois blow
up d'Antony qui a été un succès
considérable et John Barry vous a un peu
poussé à faire vous vouliez pas c'est
pas tellement ça je suis parti pour
faire un essai et puis
on m'a dit qu'il fallait que j'écris mon
nom sur le mur alors j'ai commencé très
petit comme ça et puis à chaque
troisième lettre qu'il fallait jeter en
profil donc je suis pas très fort en
maths donc
et puis tout d'un coup un fou italien
est sorti en disant pourquoi vous faites
ça c'est pour ça que vous croyez que
vous allez attraper l'oeil de le mettre
en scène vous pensez que c'est comme ça
que vous aurez du succès je pense il
pleurait quand même ma et puis Antonio a
dit voilà c'est tout coupé je voulais
juste voir si elle était émotionnelle et
puis il a dit vous avez le rôle mais je
vous donne trois pages de votre rôle
mais il va falloir vous mettre à poil
alors
je suis rentrée à la maison et c'était
correct de dire quoi je suis partie à la
maison et puis j'ai dit à John que voilà
que j'avais le rôle mais c'est pour
anthonyoni que j'ignorais qui s'était
bien sûr il a dit mais c'est quand même
si on va se mettre à poil pour quelqu'un
un tenue
mais il a dit vous allez jamais pouvoir
oser parce que vous éteignez toujours
tous les lumières tout le temps avant de
se mettre nu et donc il a dit tu aurais
jamais le courage etc justement il
fallait pas le dire parce que
vous y êtes allé
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais c'est comme ça que c'est passé
ce qu'il faut dire aussi Jane c'est que
de l'eau a pas eu un énorme succès palme
d'or à Cannes en 67 et un jour John
Barry vous appelle de New York et il
vous dit c'est incroyable les gens font
la queue tout autour de Times Square
pour pouvoir le film enfin d'un seul
coup vous avez compris que vous aviez
fait un truc très très fort très oui
j'étais enceinte donc plus personne me
reconnaissait je n'arrivais même pas à
rentrer à la projection privée de blog
parce que j'étais blonade j'étais
tellement vaste alors
j’étais un peu inquiet et j'ai envoyé ma
mère et je dis va voir si j'ai fait une
chose honteux ou elle dit mais non on
dirait que je suis dans une piscine
c'est absolument charmant après ça tout
le monde m'a dit c'est les choses le
plus choquantes qu'on puisse faire
j'avais fait j'avais fait pas une fleur
hôtel et je vais débuter
et avant ça j'avais fait une pièce de
Green green qui a fait grand scandale
parce que sera le fruit de Hudson de nos
plus grands acteurs étaient en train de
de cheeseley il agriculteurs les parties
privées de Dieu donc déjà lui il a reçu
tous les insultes possibles et en fait
moi oui avec avec blow-up ça fait un
scandale c'est le premier fois que les
filles étaient nues en fait et
paraît-il pour les pendant des
projections des mecs avec des
projections on devait des enlever des
petits bouts qui fait que le film
devenait de plus en plus court ils ont
enlevaient les images absolument alors
pourquoi il est parti John Barry
pourquoi vous êtes séparés parce que
j'étais certainement pas je ne savais
pas le garder faut savoir garder des
mecs
heureusement qu'il est parti parce que
sinon comme je t'ai dit c'est peut-être
ça les choses qu'on apprend dans la vie
c'est que quand il vous semble que c'est
une des arbres complet ça me semble un
désastre complet il était divin il était
allé onctueux je comprenais même pas
pourquoi il me regardait dans les
comédies musicales il y avait huit
autres films infiniment plus belles que
moi je me sentais comme si j'étais
bordée de nous il devait avoir eu ces
types génial il a eu trois Oscars le
jour comme infinité
en fait deux Oscars et ma fille le même
jour je me suis dit que j'ai vraiment
j'avais une chance fou en plus j'ai aimé
la musique alors c'est vrai que quand il
était parti oui je me suis dit bon
j'étais pas à la hauteur de savoir
techniquement d'être peut-être une
personne qui savait faire des trucs bien
pour le garder à ce moment-là vous
faites chercher un ringarde
non mais curieusement justement à cause
de ces désastre ça te secoue un peu
j'avais ma fille Kate il fallait gagner
des sous j'avais mon honneur quand même
je pouvais retourner chez mes parents je
l'ai fait mais après je voulais voilà
avoir des ressources à moi et quand
grand là est venu chercher une fille
vraiment je le remercie celui-là parce
que sinon toute ma carrière je n'aurais
jamais eu et j'arrive et puis je tombe
sur scène qui lui aussi était un homme
triste parce que il était quitté par
Bardou donc on n'était pas du tout les
gens aussi banal que veut dire lui je
m'en souviens très bien dans un
restaurant à Saint-Tropez moi j'étais
doux à la porte lui qui face à la porte
et puis je l'ai vu devenir blême et je
me retourne et c'est parce qu'il avait
vu Bardot et on était sur la piscine mon
film dedans donc c'était pas encore
patché et moi quand John Barrio
pour la sortir je l'ai regardé qui
partait dans la rue divinement main dans
la main et puis sais-je j'étais sur le
piano en visant
donc ça prend du temps pour se patcher
et puis après ça nous on se patch si
bien que c'est
voilà alors on va vous faire comme ça
vraiment parce que des fois des fois
vous avez tendance mais c'est très
agréable il faisait dans à parler un
petit peu beaucoup comme ça donc on va
vous faire non non on va vous faire un
truc très simple on va vous faire une
interview oui ou non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma fille c'est des portables qui sonnent
pendant votre spectacle si vous vous
retrouvez en paillette alors justement
Jane par oui ou par non mais sans faute
de français
seriez-vous prêtes à donner votre vie
pour une cause humanitaire si demain on
vous dit il y a plus de famille dans le
delta du Gange est-ce que vous seriez
prête à donner votre vie oui quel jour
est-ce que vous croyez que tous les
hommes sont égaux
oui
est-ce que vous donnez toujours à ceux
qui font la quête dans la rue non
croyez-vous qu'il y a quelque chose
après la mort
non est-ce que dans sa vie on peut
connaître plusieurs fois le grand amour
si vous trompiez votre Jules actuelle
est-ce que vous lui diriez non
est-ce que vous seriez prête à tout
quitter pour le grand amour
existe-t-il un fantasme que vous n'avez
pas encore réalisé
de tourner dans un film porno
pour 3 millions de francs
même pour 5 millions 10 millions
mais je veux pas moudre la foufoune
pour la Tchétchénie
[Musique]
est-ce que vous vous aimez non est-ce
que vous m'aimez
non plus
salut en même temps
[Applaudissements]
j'ai jamais été aussi un pied de ma vie
ça vient de la foufoune
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu